[Music]
contagious this world are entrepreneurs
we get no value to haters
[Music]
all right
so okay this will be the last podcast
we're doing till Christmas excited to
spend some time with you guys home team
Adam Tom bizdoc and Vinnie in the house
yeah uh Malik is here as well as Chris
it's always great to have Malik here
with us the real Malik uh look uh A
lot's been going on it's been a crazy uh
minute here I think zelinski is going to
talk today to Congress or something like
that coming to meet Biden Twitter musk
announced he's stepping down as CEO he's
looking for CEO crazy enough to run
Twitter we'll talk about that uh more
stuff coming up from Twitter files what
else is it Black Adam apparently they're
not renewing uh this new guy named James
uh what's his name James Gunn I think
his name is James Gunn he's not uh uh
bringing in uh Dwayne Johnson and
they're saying some of this stuff is
Rock cost Henry uh how do you say his
last name Henry Cavill Henry Cavill his
job Superman
Wells Fargo paying another multi-billion
dollar fine Argentina everything that's
going on there what happened something
big happened with Argentina last week
they did something good they did
something yeah something happened the
soccer tournament yeah and and Messi
almost got his head chopped off because
he was on top of a uh the bus and they
hit a telephone pole you know it's a
craziest record he broke like there's so
many records he broke but he broke the
record for the most liked post ever on
Instagram and the previous record
45 million to 64 million likes his post
that is insane to get that big of a
number we'll talk about that something's
going on with epic games agrees to pay
520 million dollars over FTC
investigations into fortnite privacy
violations Tom's got some content on
that bad people Disney stock on its way
to its worst year since 1974 after
Avatar sequel to the points and a little
bit of has to do with China Cuban had a
few things to say about uh uh Elon Musk
Twitter's new guidelines won't allow
certain promotions that's piss on a lot
of fans off on Twitter anyways we got a
lot of stuff to talk about but uh you
know there was some big news overnight
that I found out what's that what's this
I mean I can't believe everything that I
see on Facebook especially what's going
on these days but allegedly it's
someone's birthday today allegedly it is
your sister's birthday
is it is it not that is this fake news
I saw this pop up on Facebook I said is
this real you should text her right now
I'm like we're live and we're giving you
a freaking video
she's actually watching right now
I love them every time I see police
got something to say go ahead happy
birthday I saw it on Facebook
[Music]
[Applause]
that's Happy Birthday in Farsi for all
you people happy birthday I will see you
in two hours at the airport every time I
see Paulette every time she says the
same thing you're growing on me
I said just next thing you know
like a bacteria algae I'm just gonna
take over what do we want to do actually
I want to go she says when she doesn't
want to curse but anyway yeah where do
we want to go with this we got a lot of
stuff to get into I'm just trying to see
what direction to go you know yesterday
I had a
uh David Rubinstein on the the founder
of Carlisle Group they manage around 400
billion dollars of uh of money what's
crazy is Jerome Powell worked for him
for seven years before he became the Fed
chair at Carlisle Group Jerome Powell
was that Carlisle group seven years yeah
so 400 billion 400 billion dollars they
managed he sits on Duke's he's the
chairman of the board for Duke chairman
of the board for Smithsonian the amount
of things he's done the amount of money
he's given Kennedy sent so many
different things that he's done but uh
it was very interesting talking to him
about you know certain investing and you
know how the market looks at the you
know experts I challenge them on some of
the things on how much American people
have lost trust in experts and then
today he says everybody wants to be a
podcaster what's interesting about his
story is he's the first billionaire ever
to start a podcast really first
billionaire to start a podcast not First
YouTube to become a billionaire he's the
first billionaire to start a podcast and
he interviews people like Jeff Bezos
Bill Gates you know Jamie Diamond he's
got some of the best interviews out
there in the area of uh business and
he's got this new book come came that
came out called how to invest but I
thought it was just uh very interesting
with certain topics on you know he's got
very close relationship with Joe Biden
Joe Biden was at his Nantucket house for
Thanksgiving staying over they weren't
together he made that very clear yeah he
said I wasn't there I just lented I just
gave him the keys so I just gave him the
keys and the alarm code for yourself
yeah and and then you know some of the
conversation about Jimmy Carter years
ago that he was a part of because he
started off being part of Jimmy Carter
to where he's at today it's it's just a
all I can say is it's very interesting
how that World Views things differently
sometimes than the average person that's
dealing with the level of skepticism in
mainstream media and uh you know he said
that you know nowadays there's so many
different podcasters people don't know
who to trust people don't know who to do
this you know time you sound like you
want to say something go ahead no and I
was also impressed by what he said about
um his kids he said all my kids got
their MBA and they're launching
successfully they don't need a billion
dollar each and I was one of the
original signers on the giving pledge so
he's given it all away to things which I
have a lot of respect you know building
it up and then giving it away to all the
need City season Society don't agree
with him on everything but I I thought
that was a very Noble thing who started
the giving pledge was that was that
Gates or Buffett uh that was Buffett
yeah buff it and they're they're giving
away what 99 of their wealth is that the
premise die broke die broke live rich
die broke Pat let me get your opinion on
this the more and more I see tell me if
I'm wrong on this the more and more I
see this most billionaires
are more Democrats but more millionaires
are more Republicans do I have that
right that assessment right billionaires
had more left millionaires I don't know
the stats the stats Rob that's a that's
I mean you could go down is that
something you can get behind pretty
quickly figure it out most most
billionaires most Democrats most
billionaires are Democrats Billy Demps
you know Millies let's Google it to see
to see if there is
Google it to see are most billionaires
Democrats or Republicans are most
billionaires Democrats or Republicans
and I'm a thousand there so Google how
much what are we
you're just voting against your own
interests what if you've got billions uh
gold or lower
if you go to images that my padirgo or
American richest billion well that's
2014. click on it anyways let's just see
what it says yeah lots of change since
2014 but let's see what it says
4.2 million dollars Americans richest
families an ebook from Forbes Glimpse go
a little lower that's not saying
anything it's not showing a percentage
no it's not showing a percentage okay
yeah I don't know it's a good question
but it's like because as you're making
your money you want to just be left
alone you want to be able to do your
thing you want to be able to you know
have tax breaks everything that a lot of
you know capitalists and and people who
view right kind of stand for but once
you make the billions you want to just
you want regulation you want monopolies
you want like
you don't want you want to be left alone
yes but you want
the government regulation to be left on
that's what you see all these like Tech
billionaires in bed with government
subsidies this that the other I don't
know this is just my kind of speculation
but I figured maybe you have a strong
opinion on this yeah I don't know I
don't know what to tell you with that
part all I can tell you is it's very
interesting when when you know you get
in a circle and you're only talking to
people that are relatively in your level
you have a hard time understanding what
it was like to be a regular person okay
there's a different like I'll give you
an idea
some people are watching this
you know you've got big plans for 2023.
let's just say if you're watching this
saying I got big plans for 2023. we had
a business planning workshop this last
week it was a very powerful had a great
time we had a session last night's
strategy session at the office till late
last night five hour meeting we had last
night Tom probably the best one we've
ever had sex no joke we just unveiled
the vitamin's vision what we want to do
in 23 where we're going to be going in
the future different projects we have in
all the different leaders work in
different departments share their
insight and what they're going to be
doing but here's what I will tell you
um 2023
it it will be we gave it a name uh where
we're sitting down on time on what the
your name is going to be for the year
we're calling it The your building
character okay and to me what I mean by
your building character if you say
you're gonna do something do it okay
you're not going to get 100 score on
this you're just not because 100 means
no matter what numbers you put you're
going to hit 100 of your goals if you
hit 100 of your goals your goals were
too small if you're 20 of your goals
your goals were either out of whack and
you were not really sitting down
thinking about the goals you're just
kind of treating it like homework but
you ought to hit about 80 of your goals
when you're writing them down because
some of them should be a stretcher it's
like how the hell am I going to hit this
number what makes you fight for it but
the only reason why you will hit your
goals for 2023 is because you're more
concerned about who you're becoming as a
human being than the actual goal
character building is about saying I'm
gonna do x y z working your tail off for
hitting that goal
and Tony Brown is sitting right here and
I'm trying to find this video I got to
somewhere around here uh Antonio Brown's
sitting right here we're going back and
forth during that podcast where we're
talking to him and in one of the
sessions he says you ain't you you don't
know where I'm from I'm from Liberty
City I'm from Liberty City I'm from La
he kept saying that again I'm like dude
I'm from L.A yeah but you grew up in the
nice parts of it I'm like dude you know
Liberty City people get shot I'm like
dude in Iran we get bombed yeah yeah but
you don't understand this this I'm like
dude this is just gonna go places so I
said you know what fine no problem
Antonio Brown you know what I'm gonna do
Rob I'm gonna text this to you to show
this video I said I'm gonna go you just
declined it I'm gonna go to
Liberty City yeah and you know what I'm
going to do I'm going to go be a cash
and not a cashier a bagger at
Winn-Dixie's sick I'm gonna wear the
whole what do you call it uniform I'm
gonna wear the apron I'm gonna put the
apron on I'm gonna go up there for an
hour and act like I'm working there and
everyone's coming up to me I'm like if
you can play the video to for people to
see Eric if you guys can show this here
press play
yeah that's me right there at Liberty
City okay talking to customers that's
Heaven my cashier I just don't look like
I belong at this place
you you can you get the six four bagger
over here but you know what's funny
everybody's coming up here looking
they're like what the hell is wrong with
this guy being a bad girl right not
talking to everybody Hey Yolanda how are
you
tell me your story you know how old's
your son five months old where are the
diapers how come you're not buying any
diapers all week I can't afford any
diapers we got to get you some diapers
the mom looks at me like the grandma
like her mom not the kids mom the
grandma of the kid you we do need
diapers but we ain't got the money for
right now I said how many months five
months what aisle I go to aisle number
five and I pick up all the every single
diaper box they had for five month old
baby I pick it up I bring it she's like
no no we don't want to bite I said how
about I pay for it but you work here I
said let me just pay for it so I'm you
know I'm doing my part and I'm talking
to everybody why I want to know what
people are like in Winn-Dixie and you're
going to find out about not Winn-Dixie
in Liberty City by the way while we're
there
uh Sam got the video of this Sam if you
can send those clips to Michael to add
the video as well there's a shooting
right across the street two people get
shot they're moving by I mean this is a
he's right about what the city is like
it's not a safest place to not a good
anyways we're talking to all these
people and then long story short next
person comes actually who are you I'm
just a regular person no you're not why
are you paying for everyone's groceries
I spent probably four or five thousand
dollars buying everyone's groceries
eventually after 30 minutes everybody
was going through aisle number seven
that's so funny we gotta cleanup 45
minutes I'm like I'm only going to be
here for an hour and 15 minutes yeah but
it was it was learned as such so tell me
about the city what is this place like
where are you from what's the Liberty
City how much has changed the cop that
was there with us she was working at
Winn-Dixie 20 years ago and everybody
was talking to her she's like you
realize that at this Winn-Dixie 20 years
ago there was a shooting every day you
realize where you are so really yeah
anyways and one lady says why are you
doing this I said look man I came from a
family you know my dad was a cashier at
a 99 Cent Store uh and that was in
England and I said my dad is standing
right there my dad was standing right
next to me just like 20 feet away
watching the whole thing yeah it's a
very unique experience for this whole
thing this is my biggest challenge for
people watching this okay and what the
point I was trying to make with David
Rubinstein and then we can go into the
topics
if you're doing very very very well in
life
if 2022 was a magical year for you
financially you have more money than
you've ever had you're driving nicer
cars than you've ever driven you're
going to the best restaurants regularly
you're getting more respect than you
ever have gotten before
go to the complete opposite communities
to get some perspective to realize how
things are in different places and give
back by choice I don't like force that's
taxes I like Choice do it by choice and
learn and take your family let them also
kind of see what that looks like because
that's a paradigm shift that those need
who are doing very well but flip it if
2022 was a shittier for you you went
through a divorce it wasn't fun it was
an exciting bad breakup you know I'm
talking to one of the guys yesterday
he's going through it right now he's in
the middle of a divorce he thought it
was going to be easy it's not it's ugly
you know everything's getting involved
they didn't have anything in place it's
not a nest it's not a nice situation
that he's going through such a rough
year form if you're in a place where
things are not going right you lost four
hundred thousand dollars in Bitcoin you
were expecting to be a millionaire now
you're barely a thousand here and things
are not going right to the complete
opposite side to get a paradigm shift go
to a Ferrari dealership and ask the guy
to sit on a Ferrari and just to kind of
see how the salesperson treats you go to
a realtor and go to an open house or
five million dollar home Dream Home in a
community you'd like to live in go give
yourself a paradigm shift but whatever
you do going into 2023 the one thing
that's for sure nothing's going to
change dramatically unless if you put
all the pressure in building character
and create environments for you to have
a paradigm shift whether it's for you
your kids your family the people you
lead start 2023 with that right before
this the only reason why we started a
podcast at 9 23 is because today was a
Christmas uh what do you call it when
the school does a Christmas uh you know
like a event where the kids were doing
what they were doing I was there today
with all my kids and uh like a place it
was a Gilligan's Island play which was
awesome what time was this this was at 8
30. I just got here right uh right after
that
Hannah we're off to going and spending
time with the family for Christmas but
um you know I I I always you know think
about like you know talking to
Rubenstein I wonder if they're only
talking to billionaires if they're only
talking to people that are in their
situations if they're only talking to
rich people and not realizing the other
side does not trust mainstream media the
other side does not trust the government
you kind of have to be able to hear both
sides out we were just watching a video
by Joe manchin and Joe manchin's being
asked by uh Jake tappers are you leaving
the party he says listen man I'm gonna
vote the same the same way I've always
voted this is who I am whether I change
parties or not that's on me because I
think Kristen's Cinema so everybody's
asking if he's gonna be doing it look
create 2020 create some Paradigm Shift
moments for yourself to make 2023 the
beginning of the greatest years of your
life and it starts with being
intentional not letting you be
accidental anyways that was my biggest
thing with talking to David Rubinstein
how all that makes sense with each other
I don't know but it does to me so in my
own way that's kind of what I got from
sitting now with David Rubinstein
Paradigm Shift there's the talking
points memo with pbd
there you go whatever you want to call
that I think it makes complete that's
what you're saying fantastic I mean yeah
and and I'd go ahead and say what you're
going to say no you're talking about
um if you think ultimately what you're
saying is like it's the holiday season
and you know it's better to give than
receive I mean we talked about this on
our podcast we the other day
like you went to Win Dixie right you're
and you're seeing how the other side
lives like every single year I go to the
Special Olympics so whether you're rich
wealthy broke poor when you see people
that are just I mean this is the these
are the people who are the most hurting
in society can barely function and the
job of your job when you go to the
Special Olympics is to be a hugger your
job is to be a hugger meaning when they
finish the race it is your job to hug
them and I'm telling you the first place
finisher and the last place finisher has
the biggest smile on their face because
they finished a race so whatever you're
dealing with no matter whether it's you
know family issues money issues divorce
kids this that the other everyone's got
issues when you go to a place like that
the Special Olympics you realize holy
[ __ ] I've got some gratitude I will tell
you so I think everybody needs to do
things like that to to to have to create
Paradigm shifts for a decade we would go
to Skid Row every morning Christmas if
you were part of my sales team you have
to be at the office at four o'clock in
the morning Christmas morning imagine
what an annoying sales team to be a part
of cars would line up they're all
looking at me pissed off no makeup on
and we'd go to skidrone we'd give away
200 hamburgers all this other stuff I
think you got to do it I think for your
own sake but again the other side too
like go the other side too go stay at
the most expensive hotel and where
everybody stays at to kind of get a feel
wow this is kind of what it feels like
you got to do both and that is also an
investment you got it when I was poor I
had nothing to my name I wanted to go
rob elbows with Killers meaning like
people that were winning
and to kind of say this is what this
lifestyle looks like at Rodeo Drive
Beverly Hills Hotel this is what it
feels like at Montage this is what it
feels like at Pelican wow this is what
it feels like at the you know Pebble
Beach interesting okay cool I just spent
this money but damn I want more of this
I want my family to experience this what
if one day you're you're the question
becomes the what if one day when any
time a sentence starts with what if one
day imagine if one day we need to spend
more using that sentence in 2022-2023 in
a positive way what if one day your
dreams do become a reality anyways it's
a time to be thinking about that I don't
want to go too much longer on this let's
just go into topics beautiful but that's
some thoughts right there okay so Tom uh
let's start off with uh let's start off
with Disney let's start off with Disney
so page number six we're gonna go do
some business and we're going to Twitter
files and I'll give a shout out to our
sponsor here in a minute as well it's a
gun company by the way out of all yes
all right so Disney stock on its way to
worst years since 1974. after Avatar
sequel disappoints this is market watch
story this is share sank nearly five
percent was nearly uh to its lowest
level since March 2020 on Monday after
the Blockbuster Sequel and one of the
priciest movies in Hollywood history
fell short of the hype in its opening
weekend Avatar the way of water hauled
in 134 million dollars domestically and
had the second largest global opening of
2022 but fell short of tracking
estimates on base on Advanced U.S ticket
sales and disappointed and won the
biggest markets for the franchise China
Disney had opened in open to uh had
hoped to clean
up in China where the first movie in
2009 did Blockbuster business the way of
water earned 57.1 million dollars there
which did think the scrap in a Wall
Street Journal report as disappointing
but understandable the problem is nobody
wants to go to the cinema because
they've been told that covet is
extremely dangerous Tony Chambers Disney
Global head of theatrical distribution
said Tom what are your thoughts on the
story well first of all this is why
Disney has a new CEO folks this is why
Bob Iger is back in doing a uh his own
version of uh you know a reality show to
rebuild the house so the avatars can be
just fine and I think this can be the
biggest movie of all time if you think
about everything you have to do to put
on an event it's like we do the Vault
event here at uh valuetainment you you
can't move the date you can't change
things there's hotels there's travel
everything is in place this movie was in
place and no one could have predicted
just how big World Cup was going to be
number one no one could predicted that
kovid would have another wave come
through and China starts telling people
to stay home or that you would have
civil unrest in many parts of China over
Apple labor practices at those factories
yet yet so I don't look at it this way
oh Avatar didn't meet expectations I
find it kind of unbelievable they did as
much as they did against those headwinds
so they got a new CEO they got this
something I think Avatar is going to be
just fine I think this is going to be
sitting there at number one one
when everything is counted later on this
is the biggest movie biggest box on Pat
you saw you saw it right yeah I did you
like like if you and I'm a movie buff I
haven't seen it yet I heard I heard two
conflicting sides from Maverick and
everybody they said Maverick said it was
three hours and 10 minutes he goes they
didn't need that extra 10 minutes after
three minutes or three hours your body's
like okay what's going on what are you
from from rating it from storyline I
mean Graphics I mean they've had 15
years with technology what do you what
would you give what would you rank the
movie I I listen I thought the the story
was great it started very slow you know
they had to kind of bring you back
obviously the maybe the reason was
because it's been so long I don't know I
think the movie could have been done in
two hours and 40 minutes it didn't need
to be three hours and 12 minutes I would
have been fine with two hours and 40
minutes I agree I'm okay with that part
uh it's very emotional at the end the
story is about how your kids eventually
lead your family and parents end up
needing kids to rely on which is a very
emotional message that the way he did it
it was very very there he talked at your
heart constantly for the last 40 minutes
I mean it I've walked out of movies so
many times in the first half uh half
hour one hour done if you do that with
this movie you'll be disappointed
because the last 30-40 minutes is worth
it here's the other part China of course
makes sense for them to have the kind of
numbers that they have so they can't be
disappointed with that you can't do
anything when politics get involved in
China that's not the movie's fault
that's not Cameron's fault he says we
need to make 2 billion to break even
that is an insane number to say they
need to break even here's the other
thing that nobody is talking about on
why Avatar didn't hit the numbers you
ready Avatar came out the weekend of the
World Cup yeah who the hell is talking
Avatar nobody I mean you got three
billion people that watch the World Cup
give or take little over three billion
people you think three billion people
are sitting there saying so Adam what
did you think about Avatar if Avatar
would let me give you a prediction if
Avatar would have waited one week on
when to come mod they would have done
numbers and even more they screwed up on
timing what are you doing coming out on
the weekend of World Cup like honestly
Mr CMO whoever the CMOS what the hell
were you thinking yeah like you know the
calendar you know when the World Cup
freaking is you can't change it one
weekend yeah you can't go one weekend
before or one weekend after like I
thought the timing of it was out of
whack but I will tell you this
I think this number is going to there's
some people that are upset with the fact
that they showed pregnant Warriors I
don't know if you saw that or not
they're already getting back yeah the
wall mob is starting they're already
talking yeah if you want to like the the
uh the whole concept of you know uh no
not the walk mob the the yeah exactly
the whole like they wanted a pregnant
Warrior to say Hey you know we wanted to
kind of highlight women yeah we felt
sympathy for women pregnant so we want
to say that pregnant women can be
Warriors up fine I understand what he's
trying to do I don't think it makes any
sense uh to be quite Frank with you I'm
sure back in the days you didn't have a
choice
if you were having to fight and I do
believe back in the days if a pregnant
mother had to be forced to protect her
kids she probably would have fought uh
so it may not resonate with the average
person today uh I was talking to
somebody the other day who said you know
my mom gave birth to me I said yeah my
mom also gave birth she says no no you
don't understand my mom was walking and
all of a sudden you know she's not in
America she's living in Mexico I was
born
and she's holding me with my umbilical
cord and she went to the neighbor and a
neighbor who was half blind no joke cut
it and that's how I was born now today
if you say that to the average person
what would they say what an
irresponsible mom what's wrong with it I
mean a thousand years ago everybody was
doing that it's not like you were going
to the doctor calling Blue Cross Blue
Shield saying hey can I set up my
c-section that was none of that thousand
years ago it's a different time so a
little bit of reach there was no lgbtq
type of a thing where parents can feel
safe about that part when they're
watching this James Cameron didn't play
the games with that I do think this is
going to end up making a ton of money
and it's not going to slow down that's
what I would say about Avatar well it'll
hit HBO or something within what a month
uh I don't know I've got a movie
recommendation for the people out there
um this might be a little controversial
uh we're talking about Avatar we're
talking about Black Adam you know how
what number are we on on The Avengers or
whatever don't listen to this message if
you have kids if you're married with
kids or you know if you're taking your
girl on a date night but if you're a
dude out there you're 16 and older yeah
here's what movie you should watch this
year
zero movies okay if you're working and
you don't have money saved up you're not
in shape you're 20 pounds overweight you
haven't done a business plan yet you
don't have a chick in your life you're
not doing anything you don't have a
purpose you haven't done your business
plan you haven't done anything you get
to watch zero movies this year you get
to watch zero Netflix shows this year
there's no video games for you this year
until you clean up your act there's so
many men out there that are watching
movies that know that they're on
Avengers 17 they're on Superman seven
they're on Spider-Man 19 I watch zero
movies you guys are talking about Avatar
that's great you've got kids respect the
kids need to see that if I don't have
kids or if I'm not on a date with my
girl there's no movies for you you're
struggling homie like I'm just saying
most dudes out there two two out of
three people in America live in paycheck
to paycheck you don't get to see movies
until you're off the paycheck to
paycheck wheel that's my opinion I
haven't gone I haven't gone because
there hasn't been anything worth me
watching but I mean I'm a complete
opposite I know you know I'm a movie
buff me Mario test me all the time Mario
will say
when it comes to hip-hop I stopped with
Biggie and all them back in the day and
then when it comes to films but what I
mean kind of I I I would go if it was
good but off of Adam's thing how
expensive is for for 3D how much is the
ticket popcorn food drink for one is
perfect one person's experience how much
is it bad for 3D I can't even tell you I
don't I don't know I buy the tickets
online and 14 bucks 15 bucks 20 bucks no
I mean right now they're like for for
what's what's the 3D no for three 3D
soda and a popcorn I'd be willing about
national average about 30 bucks because
I think that's gonna be like a 19 ticket
right that was gonna say at least a 20
14 bucks there you go this is for
regular yeah regular ticket yeah but
that's matinee so it's one o'clock for
3D I heard it was like almost forty
dollars really plus everything yeah you
have to wear the goggles and all that
[ __ ] it's not cheap bro so I could see
where Adam's like every because I mean
some people watch two two movies a week
there you go 20 and 43 cents
forms 10 bucks and a drink you're
spending 40 bucks
that's it for a person I can't afford it
that is insane I I don't I don't
disagree I will tell you for me when I
was broke and I was busting my ass
movies were my therapy uh uh for me to
go to matinee get away from everybody
and watch I Am Legend with a form of
Escape without needing a therapist yeah
movies have uh uh uh have done that for
me but we understand Adam is an
unorthodox type of guy he doesn't
believe in driving yeah he has his horse
parked outside he comes in uh Tom you're
trying to say something on the movie
side I think you were gonna say
something no I am but I will
um you know I think there's a lot of
movies out there that are not exactly
family friendly and I I'm really
thrilled to see Avatar
um my girls my kids they love the
Marvels they love the Avengers they love
that series
um we love Top Gun so there's there's
glimmers of Hope in there that are
movies but I agree with Pat you know you
look at it like this I think a movie is
a great experience and I think it's an
uplifting experience because you you
drop down into an immersive story and
you get to look at the story and it
touches you I am Legend things like that
and I I disagree I think movies is a
rather cost effective escape and you to
your point Vinnie you don't have to go
to the 7 30 you know um Friday night you
know you know high def theater with 3D
for real D and they gotta pay for the
glasses and everything you know you you
can you can go to standard theaters and
enjoy but I think it's an Escape there's
positive messages it stirs your souls
figures your thoughts I'm on that
favorite movie of all time give your
favorite movie uh me it's Godfather too
okay what's yours
Good Fellas what's yours Jaws it's yours
anything with Vince Vaughn swingers
swingers
what do you got what about you I mean
Godfather too I would put Man on Fire
probably Gladiator I'll put Gladiator at
the top but I can watch it here's my
point those movies are like they don't
make movies like they used to it's all
just marvel I agree nonsense yeah I
agree with that yeah and by the way to
you to your point because I know you
have strong feelings on on movies when
you were going because you've told that
story you'd go by yourself yep
what phase of your life were you in at
that point 27 years old okay yeah so
here's where I'm going with this you
were in your building phase you were
creating a company you were working at
uh wfg at the point you would yeah so
the point is this your Escape for those
two hours because you need to decompress
for all the [ __ ] you were dealing with
this is the one you were in the Army
this wasn't when you were at Bally's
this is when you couldn't afford Army we
would watch movies in the barracks
you're making 600 bucks a month dude you
can't do a lot of things I feel you on
that yeah but I guess my point is this
it if you're like for instance for me
I'm I'm reading I'm watching YouTube I'm
reading articles I don't watch any TV
but if I need Escape I'll watch a half
hour of Seinfeld or whatever yes I do
agree you need some Escape you're
starting to really pissed me off
honestly no no but most people I
honestly don't struggling I have to tell
you about this gun then if that's what
you're gonna do I'm gonna tell you about
this gun yeah I started talking trash
about movies Pat pulls out a gun this
right here folks let me just tell you
for me we get a lot of sponsors
yesterday company came here to the
office and they they wanted us to
sponsor and I just told you guys so
listen I understand your offer on the
taper is very attractive it's a massive
multi-six figure check for sponsorship I
don't use the product
I don't use the product and I you know
I'm not I can't talk on the product I
know nothing about the product anything
that I talk about either I understand
that there's a need for it as a business
person or I use it this is one of the
companies that we reached out to Berna a
guy named John who works for us he's
nearly a seven figure earner out of
Orlando I want to say he shows me this
in his Lambo he says Pat look what I
just bought I said what are you doing
carrying a gun here is that legal he
says yeah this is legal you can carry
this you can have it in your car it's
legal you just have to be 18 I said
you're carrying a gun I said maybe in
Florida now and he says Nope all other
states I said how's that even possible
he says because it's not bullets it's
projectiles and I said projectiles what
do you mean he says this projectile when
you shoot somebody with this projectile
you're not going to kill them you're not
going to go to jail it it drops them
and they can't breed for 30 to 35
minutes they can't breathe I mean they
can't break there's pepper there's
pepper projectile you literally if you
see the video for this so they came down
their CMO CEO flew out they came out
here their vitainers they brought the
whole crew did a whole video on it they
had a bunch of our guys shoot the guns
outside they have one of them that's a
rifle as well anyways eventually I said
look guys if you're a salesperson if
you're an Uber driver if you're somebody
that say you're doing ubereats you do
lift you're out there running
appointments you run a small business
but you don't want to have a gun because
you don't want to get arrested and
you're not trying to kill anybody you're
just trying to stop somebody so you can
call the cops so they can come to you
and you have enough ample time for
people to stop you may want a gift for
2023 for somebody you may want to buy
buy them a burner gun and this burner
gun when I called I said I want this
thing to be optional for everybody to
buy I want our guys to have a discount
so that's exactly what we negotiated the
link is right there if you're trying to
buy something to protect protect
yourself going into next year some next
year is going to be Europe investigation
it's going to be a very very weird year
with a lot of people going back and
forth especially coming closer to
election time highly recommend you buy
one of these for you if you have a wife
that's the sales highly recommend you
buy it for her your daughter yourself
your sales team uh anybody and everybody
that's out there seeing a lot of
different people but you don't want to
get your your pro Second Amendment or
you're not a proseccoment person this is
the gun for you to make sure you can
protect yourself the moment you point
this at somebody the first thing they
see is all they think about it's a real
gun and you can protect yourself again
legal in all 50 states let's put a link
below so people can take advantage of it
Adam you really pissed me off that's why
I wanted to kind of go around yeah again
I'll never talk trash
thank you very much to our sponsor Berna
uh the bizdoc Babe has one that's uh in
the car seriously yes she stops forget
yes I do I bought one and if she stops
for gas she knows she's got basically
pepper spray on steroids if somebody
comes up because there's you know you
you see around the United States there's
muggings that happen right there at the
where you're getting gas and other
things like this so I love it I feel I
feel better that she's safe oh and I saw
I just saw pictures from the air and
showed us of the welts in this oh my God
let me explain something to you I've
been have you ever been hit paintball of
course I got hit with one in the back I
dropped the gun and I'm like I am
finished I'm not playing anymore
congratulations now we imagine this with
pepper when you're having a hard time
with eyes breathing all of that and Pat
and here's the thing because I'm a gun
owner I have like seven guns still in
Cali I I have uh I have guns here it's
Once you pull the trigger on a gun in
real life real time even though you're
protecting your life if that person
lives that's coming to attack you to
kill you they can sue you for trying to
kill them with this gun with this Weapon
It's still because mind you they have
pepper and they just have regular
kinetic well just hit you and drop you
without the pepper but I'm telling you
right now that that's one of the I'm how
much can we get a discount on this bag
oh by the way anybody that buys it to
get a discount anybody
anything you buy you buy the projectiles
the guns the rifle they give you a full
discount uh it's on the link that we
have to go through it you can get a
bunch of discount when you buy their
products yeah I mean by the way people
are going to buying two three thousand
dollars worth of stuff because they're
buying three four four friends and
family but uh anyways that's great so
there you have it that's one thing I
personally reached out they haven't paid
us this is just purely a affiliate deal
we don't do affiliates with anybody we
only do paid sponsorship this is one
where I said I trust the product people
need this by the way the PD uses it the
EA uses it a bunch of government
organizations use it uh for themselves
as well okay all right so let's go into
let's wrap up the Avatar part do you
know what's the crazy story about the
Avatar is uh the story with Matt Damon
where James Cameron told them get over
it Titanic director James Cameron tells
me entertainment to stop beating himself
up or turning down Avatar in 2009 for
Bourne film in 2019 Damon 52 revealed he
was courted by director James Cameron to
Star an avatar in 2009 but rejected a
deal that would have been
seen him get 10 of the movie box office
profits earning him you ready 250
million dollars but the Titanic Movie
Maker has little Sympathy for the
Hollywood heavyweight and has said he
needs to get over it he's beating
himself up for this and I really think
you know Matt you're kind of a like one
of the biggest movie stars in the world
get over it but he had to do another
Bourne film which was on his Runway and
there was nothing we could do about that
so he had to regretfully decline
there's a certain thing like by the way
almost everybody in Hollywood has a
story like this of course almost
everybody in Hollywood has a storyline
like Will Smith with uh uh Matrix Perry
Will Smith was supposed to be Neo but he
was like nah I'm good I don't think he's
going to do that well
yeah future or whatever
like how long do you know how do you
know your agent has a big yeah your
agent how do you know which he was going
to do what I mean exactly you saw what's
going on with DC right now dropping you
know Superman Henry dropping The Rock
Dwayne Johnson where he had to tweet
about it yesterday well what happened
yeah he tweeted about it yesterday
saying my passionate friends I wanted to
give you a long awaited black Adam
because he stopped following Marvel and
he stopped I'm sorry he stopped
following DC's Instagram account and he
stopped following Black Adam on
Instagram like wait a minute why did you
unfollow them what so update regarding
the character's future in the new DC uh
Universe James Gunn and I connected and
Black Adam will not be in their first
chapter storytelling Howard DC and seven
bucks have agreed to continue exploring
the most valuable ways Black Adam can be
utilized in a future DC Universe
chapters James and I have known each
other for years and have always rooted
for each other to succeed it's no
different now and I will always root for
DC uh and Marvel to win and win big you
guys know me and I have very thick skin
and you can always count on me to be
direct with my words
uh these decisions made by James and DC
leadership represent their vision of DCU
through their creative lens after 15
years of Relentless hard work to finally
make Black Adam I'm very proud of the
film we delivered for fans worldwide I
will always look back on fan reaction to
Black Adam when tremendous uh gratitude
humility and love we did great etc etc
thank you thank you thank you what a
hell of a month and now we all need some
more terramano so nice
and speaking of uh Dwayne I mean Joe
Rogan's still going after him talking
about coming clean with he did when did
he go out there we're doing steroids
because I see it in the miscellaneous
but what I'm saying is like we we
interviewed what's his name recently
right uh liver King did you see the
video recently of him in Hollywood he's
on Rodeo you know that big intersection
powered by shopping and he's standing
there and some lady with a camera I
don't know if she was TMZ or not she
goes hey what are you doing and he goes
steroids what's it look like I'm doing
and then he goes leave me alone lady he
goes in the middle of the intersection
and starts doing deadlifts so he's back
at it and I love that Adam was like so
you're going to stop doing series he
just looked he was like hell no yeah
this is it back
so he's she's like do you see somebody
working out he goes I'm doing stairways
that's the only way to be okay and the
name is lever King he rewinded it he
said at the beginning Pat looks steroid
yeah hey what's going on steroids
pause it
pause it you know what though good for
him good for him though that he doesn't
give a [ __ ] anymore
the one question I asked I said Hey
listen you got caught bro why would you
stop steroids at this point oh my God so
clearly you're addicted to it go for it
it's like no I owe it to the people I'm
like you don't know [ __ ] I think I think
he's doing your stairs
for his investors Adam he had to be like
you know guys I'm really sorry and you
know but now it's just like steroids he
doesn't give a [ __ ] he can have a needle
in his neck nobody would give a damn I
don't know dude and he walked into the
middle of the intersection he starts
doing that so what was your point you're
saying that he's still calling out the
rock doing steroids I mean we're me and
him I don't know if you guys paid
attention that much because me and Pat
I'm huge into working out was huge when
I was in the military we knew that he
was on stairs did you know liver King
look did you even care I don't know
looking at the liver King I kind of
speculated maybe he was joking
he was juicing okay we all know that but
like the rock he's America's like he's
the A-list number one like all all these
guys what do you do you even care like
because I know some people don't give a
damn if he comes clean or comes like a
joke you were talking about the rock I
think that's what we're talking about so
I'm saying this is like the rock is he
supposed to I don't know why Like Pat
why is the rock why is Rogan so all over
the rock yeah I will tell you why I will
tell you why you know back in the 90s
these bodybuilders which was a very uh
unique thing that these guys did and it
was kind of funny It's the funniest
video which one old video of
bodybuilders with their faces let me see
if I can find this clip uh old um
uh
face yeah that's the one where they're
saying you know I use steroids yeah I do
this but they have their faces blurry as
if nobody can tell who it is because
there's only a few people that are that
massive and they're telling the truth
about steroids but no bodybuilder wanted
to say that they're on steroids it was
like that one secret thing that you
wouldn't tell anybody yeah everybody
knew they were doing it yeah nobody
wanted to reveal that they're doing it
right kind of like smoking weed back in
the days was like Hey this guy's smoking
weed you know he's this where today it's
kind of like yeah okay you know people
look in a different way not go we're not
endorsing it we're just saying it's you
want to smoke cigarettes oh you want to
smoke weed go today you know when you're
like I'm naturally this big right I'm
naturally this big this is all natural
let's relax bro like you know when it's
like these are my natural breasts yeah
we had we had one lady that we work with
where
I I was there when she got the the
procedure done 15 years later in a
meeting saying mine are natural I'm like
this so some people are like listen man
what what do you well like what do you
get from saying that like yeah so that
is the part where some people just don't
like when if you're on it just say
you're on it no one cares about steroids
the way they did 30 years ago but some
people just want to say I'm naturally
like this because I have great genetics
yeah because that's on the different
story though back in some because trt
I'm getting Facebook ads of hey if
you're low on testosterone they'll give
you an you know you can get injections
every week trt but that is that it's a
form of steroids that was an ass is it
is that still serious so then
technically Joe Joe Rogan admits that
he's on it he's on trt of course he's
talked about it openly but again
why why do 11 million people tune into
Joe Rogan
interesting good good interviews and
he's honestly Straight
From the Heart I'm just Joe Rogan this
is who I am I do steroids I smoke with
I'm not going to drink this month I can
do you know such and such we're going to
do this and we're going to do that and
he opinions I don't know I used to I
like Bernie Sanders I don't know about
this now I like this he's just like he's
evolving in front of your face
everybody's growing up with him like you
know if you were to say who Joe is Joe
is the modern day Johnny Carson for
podcasts people freaking loved Johnny
Carson period so all he's saying is if
you're using it do just talk about your
use them who gives a [ __ ] nobody cares
but don't act like you're naturally that
big because you're not yeah and Rogan's
also a renaissance man whether it's
comedy whether it's UFC whether it's
intellectual whether it's asking good
questions whether it's like I saw him
just he does his ice bath thing every
morning it hurts it's just he's so
well-rounded and people respect him uh
and I don't understand the beef with
with with the rock though yeah that's
what I was curious about the climb that
tree there there is there is conflict
out there because the Rock's been in
men's health talking about Cod that how
much Cod he eats every day he puts it
the fish yeah okay puts in these
containers and it's like two and a half
pounds of cod every day with no oil no
butter and so there have been times
where he seems like he's gone out there
on a limb Pat and to say oh this is my
this is my routine I lift it this time
and so I was just curious what that
spark was that got Rogan to say hey dude
I think he doesn't like [ __ ] artists
and by the way there's a part of it that
here's what another thing people don't
like about what rocks done a couple
times which is is uh well I I support
the stuff that he does I buy his shoes I
have his shirt I've watched Black Adam I
thought it was a okay movie I thought it
was better than other DC movies I don't
say it's the greatest DC movie of all
time
but uh you know it's almost a feeling I
got with uh talking to her guest
yesterday
is so concerned about what everybody in
their world will say like he comes out
supporting Joe Rogan and then a video
comes out of Joe Rogan of what he said
15 years ago very disappointed to see
this I can't support that and then what
it's like okay you know I understand you
know you're doing what you're doing and
then same thing he did with Logan Paul
where hey he's doing all this stuff with
Logan and telling Logan take all the
picture of us down because they had the
same agent that's probably the part that
doesn't sit well uh with Joe yeah I
don't know I haven't spoken to Joe about
this but that's probably what doesn't
sit well which I may be fully wrong I'll
tell you what's unique about Joe because
whether you're talking about our guests
yesterday whether you're talking about
the rock whether you're talking about
politicians A-list actors once you've
made it
you don't want to you know you don't
want to say anything or do anything to
put you back to normalcy like you just
want to play it safe it's almost like
that conversation we brought up
yesterday when you spoke to the
billionaire yeah where he basically said
there's two types of people in the world
there's the people who've already made
their billions and they just want to
keep it versus the person that's still
on the come up and trying to grind and
trying to make that money but if you're
if you're in this camp and you've you're
already worth hundreds of millions of
dollars of billions of dollars or you're
a public figure the last thing you want
to do is get you know chopped down and
go back to down to the bottom of the
totem pole everything we've seen with me
too and cancel culture and you know
believe all women everything you got to
play it close to the vest these days and
I think that's why people respect Rogan
is because despite being an a-lister
despite making all the money he's still
like I'm still me baby I'm still me and
that's why he has so much respect but
most people are going to kind of play it
close to the vest so they don't have to
deal with their look remember business
together I expect you to defend me I
expect you to support me I expect you to
to you know uh have my back there's a
relationship kind of like all the people
you know Joe they have that relationship
but you know if you're off I'm gonna say
hey man you're off you know I I don't
agree and then we can hash it out and
have a conversation on certain things
that we do some of it is private some of
it is public some of it is no one's
business on what you do you you know
what I'm saying and then in this space
like when you're somebody that's the
best in your space chose the goat in his
space and rock is a high speed actor of
all time he's uh he's the goat of his
space in you know 124 million dollars he
made in a year I think those records are
going to be broken two years ago Forbes
said he made one 24 year in 2019. that's
a big number right there to make as an
actor there's a mutual respect of like
Federer hanging out with Tiger Woods
Roger Federer doesn't say you know what
tiger after what came out with those 16
girls you and I can no longer talk to
each other yeah can you imagine if Roger
said that it's like I don't know I I
don't listen they have a relationship
Roger and tiger Michael Jordan
all I'm saying is goats with goats
there's a certain level of mutual
respect you ought to have for that but
Hollywood makes some of these guys
actually scared and they back off a
little bit because they're worried about
what the public is it's the life you
live like what rock what the uh uh Tate
calls out
do what he uses the Matrix is they're
they're they're bowing Down to What a
publicist is telling them to say okay
and and you ought to have a conversation
with that person but there's different
kind of publicist like we had a galver
at our house two nights ago I said uh he
says look let me tell my specialty is
here's my specialties
uh challenges companies go through where
it's like social media or online crisis
you're going through and everybody's
targeting your definition of character
let me tell you what the traditional PR
form will tell you to do traditional PR
firm will tell you here's the format of
the letter to write of the tweet and the
video to make on how to apologize he
says that's not us here's what we do we
say yeah I effed up here I man for this
but let me also go back and say this
and I boom so the format of Hollywood is
this format I'm sorry I apologize
I'll get better which is fine I get
better is fine but it's constant like
fear of losing this
Spotlight the favors from Hollywood it's
too much and look some people can do it
there's a lot of people that cannot do
it there's a lot of people that cannot
do this kind of and and those are the
guys that are doing it's almost like in
football like when you're playing you're
playing defense or offense like if
you're up by three touchdowns with two
minutes left you're just going to
prevent defense so if you're making 250
million dollars a year you're the rock
like just don't screw this up yeah just
don't screw this up so only a few people
are willing to just put their neck on
the line and Rogan's one of them trumps
one of them and they're saying yeah I'm
worth billions but I don't care if half
the country hates me or I don't care if
I piss people off I'm gonna go for what
I want so like them or not you got to
respect those people that don't play it
close to the vest awesome let's talk
about this 1.7 trillion dollar bill uh
that they're putting ahead of us more
money to print folks just so you know
lawmakers unveil 1.7 trillion dollar
bill to avoid shutdown boost Ukraine AP
News Congressional leaders unveiled a
government-wide 1.7 trillion dollar
spending package Tuesday that includes
another large round of a to Ukraine
nearly a 10 boost in defense spending
and roughly four it says 40 billion is
46 billion mostly to assist communities
across the country recovering from
drought hurricane and other natural
disasters I think we're over 120 billion
right now given to Ukraine the bill
which runs for 4 155 Pages includes 772
billion dollars for non-defense
discretion program in 855 858 for
defense the spending package includes 45
billion dollars in emergency systems to
the Ukraine it would be the biggest
American infusion of assisting yet to
Ukraine above even President Biden's 37
billion dollar emergency request and
ensured that funds flows to the war
effort for months to come legislation
also includes historic revisions to
Federal Election law that aim any future
presidents candidates from trying to
overturn
by the way here's an interesting number
to give to you guys uh what a portion of
the number went to when I tell you this
I don't know how you're going to react
to it I thought I was a little bit
surprised by this number here's what it
was here's what it was
2.6 billion dollars went to U.S
attorneys for January 6 attack
prosecution how much 2.6 billion billion
billion dollars Trump's net worth on let
me say that one more time do you hear
what I said billion or a million billion
2.6 bill by the way if you're like let
me not say this no I believe so people
are thinking like so uh
2.6 billion just went to lawyers okay
let me give you this uh CNN article just
go to CNN article that says the 1.7
trillion just type in 1.7 trillion 1.7
trillion CNN go to the first article
that says here's what's in the one
potato so keep going lower just
everybody knows what the story is coming
from go lower lower lower lower lower
right around there if you can zoom in a
little bit if you can zoom in a little
bit what do you see it or no 2.6 the
bill will provide 2.6 billion dollars
for U.S attorneys which would include
funding efforts to the further support
prosecutions related to The General 36
attack on the capital and domestic
attack
2.6 billion dollars in legal fees Jesus
Christ
I mean am I the only one that reads this
and says what the okay so let's break it
do you know how many how many lawyers
you would have to give 2.6 million
dollars in fees for this let's do the
math okay what's 2.6 billion dollars
divided by say a thousand take say they
found a thousand names that they're
going to do they're going to be giving a
thousand lawyers 2.6 million dollars
thousand that's it a thousand lawyers
are gonna get 2.6 million dollars what
are we talking about and by the way by
the way this is prosecution not defense
defense is What expenses prosecution you
build an indictment you put it on the
table yeah by the way another 11.3
billion goes to the FBI okay another 11
points the worst 39 billion goes to the
justice department so I mean they're
just and then they're doing a ban on
Tick Tock a couple things they had
didn't make it in there but Ukraine gets
another 40 some billion dollars what are
your thoughts on this Adam with this 1.7
trillion dollar bill
um well I haven't gotten to all the
details but I think we can all realize
that whatever the bill is whatever the
proposal is is not the law meaning like
they're gonna negotiate this so we you
know whether you went to civics class in
eighth grade the house proposes this the
Senate gets to vote on it they negotiate
this thing could be less than
a trillion at the end of the day here so
I mean I'm glad that we're highlighting
some of the nonsense because there's
going to be arguments there's going to
be filibusters there's going to be all
sorts of uh
points and counterpoints and we'll see
where it ends up I I there's you know
it's it does seem egregious however I
remember not too long ago when one
trillion dollars was a big deal now
we're talking multi-trillion dollar
spending bills and it's just the norm so
it doesn't get out of control here's my
question to you how much after all that
said and done how much do you think that
2.6 billion would go down because mind
you that's one question number two the
fact that they're trying to get that
much for these people is it's ridiculous
Brian for another 45 billion dollars to
Ukraine and then Rob what do you say Rob
Rob actually read all four thousand uh
155 Pages Rob would you say about the
salmon yes 65 million dollars are going
to go to uh restoring Pacific salmon
populations 3 million for what they call
Bee friendly highways and then an
additional 5 million in further spending
for salmon dude here's and and and
sometimes it's not what's in a bill that
they're going to spend it on sometimes
it's what they prohibit and what is
prohibited that not one penny in this
1.7 billion dollar bills
1.7 trillion
not one penny can go toward border
defense that one I read that today it's
a clause in the bill one penny can be
it's in the bill that says none of this
appropriation may be directed to border
defense but that they are spending 410
million dollars towards border security
for other nations including such as
Jordan Lebanon Egypt Tunisia uh Tanzania
Tunisia and Omen come on Malik
what so so here's a question
Republican Democrat and dependent
libertarian I don't give a [ __ ] about
politics whatever party you're a part of
what do you mean not a penny is going to
be going to the border and we're having
two million people record-breaking
exactly amount of people coming up here
fentanyl issues that we're having like
you know how do you process that will
you say zero dollar is going to be spent
on the board but we're spending it on
other people how do you process that
well I think what's happening right now
is so the new Congress comes in what
early January January 20th so basically
we all we all know we just had the
midterms a month and a half ago whatever
uh
this happens every two to four years
where before the new Congress comes in
they're going to try to get some [ __ ]
passed you know what's the term that
they talk about pork spending or pork
belly where you just kind of throw in a
bunch of nonsense into a bill and be
like let's get this let's get this as
sort of like a wish list you're you're
right and we'll see what happens what do
you feel about this to Pat's question
now I didn't interrupt you I'm not
supposed to be interrupting you but
you're doing your job at that though but
okay your question
I got the World Cup of interruptions
what do you think about okay that's
that's what's happening but what do you
think about what's in that and that to
say nothing for border security yeah
well I think that's unfortunate I think
what's going on in the border right now
is a mess but I mean look you think
we're going to solve the border security
right now on this podcast it's been a
[ __ ] mess out of 20 years do you
realize like nice but hang on a second a
podcast is to Give opinions I agree it's
not to give like regular like uh just uh
questions being asked what do you think
I think that yes we should have some
money going towards border security But
ultimately what am I saying here yeah
this is a negotiation we're acting like
this is the end-all be-all this is
already trying to finish this up before
Christmas yeah but we'll see if that
happens I guarantee you when we're going
to look back at this in a couple weeks
or in a couple months it'd be like yeah
that [ __ ] turned out to be none of what
they that they that they proposed it's a
proposal so in any negotiation you start
here and you end up here so we'll see
what happens here I and I'm saying this
this is my opinion Okay the reason that
the left wants all these open borders is
because say what you want all these
people are coming in are votes and I'm
not saying the illegals can vote but
their children their grandchildren
they're trying to destroy us and
tradition I don't care what anybody says
bro you think that these people are so
pro-immigration illegals because they
love these people really think about
that but I know a bunch of liberal
Cycles in California I'm like you you're
so open up come on every everybody come
in what are you doing to help them
you're not letting them come into your
freaking house what oh remember Adam you
always say follow the money okay follow
why not one dollar for securing the
Border why are they so open why do they
love open borders those people's kids
grandkids all becomes votes and that
trust me when they come in they say hey
remember who let you in here the the
right the Republicans were like the hell
with you their racist you're rapist but
now remember Democrat always vote
Democrat and that's how these cats keep
you're right you're right period And by
the way they get to vote too you go in
the state of California and you can go
get an ID and with that ID you can then
vote and that's why they don't want
voter identification and they say oh
that's vote suppression yeah it is in a
way it is vote suppression because you
want illegals to vote so by your
definition on the other side their
definition it's vote suppression but
it's them voting too you're correct but
I add to that that they want the people
walking across not just their children
grandchildren they want them voting too
it's a voting Block it's a voting block
for socialist control and didn't they in
New York Pat do you remember I guess in
New York they passed the law where can
you look that up robberly fast bro that
in New York illegals can can vote now I
don't know for my old candidate or or
for the presidency but New York voting
law uh non-citizen I think they allowed
non-citizens to vote what happened this
year what I will say is I don't
understand the whole well you the the ID
to vote thing that should not be a big
big deal you got to have an ID to go get
liquor you got to get ID to go to the
airport you got to go to ID to go
anywhere
Georgia I don't know like it was racist
yeah I think that's uh I I I'm happy
that you agree with that but it's like
you have to always say why why why why
are they so anti they're helping borders
overseas but they don't give a [ __ ]
about us here
120 140 billion dollars to Ukraine 400
million dollars to other people's border
not one penny to us 2.6 billion dollars
to lawyers for January 6. that's giving
a thousand lawyers 2.61 million dollars
it's a it's a it's a very weird
situation where again the average person
has to sit there and say
like do they think the voters are dumb
like you know are these guys that are
sitting there negotiating are they
really pushing the envelope are they all
kissing each other's ass to help be
re-elected I don't know I I don't know
again another reason why the American
people don't trust these people as much
as they did before the American people
don't trust mainstream media and the
government as much as they did before
they can go back and negotiate and see
what happens
but just the fact that you're not even
putting the issue of the Border there
says a lot about you FYI this is why
2023 is going to be investigations
Galore all year long all year long it's
going to be investigations especially if
McCarthy takes over
just not to go off the subject what
investigation do you think the I mean
it's the FBI who's going to go after the
FBI this is the second time that they
were caught meddling with the election
2016 they did it with Hillary and the
collusion it was all [ __ ] with Peter
struck and Lisa Page and all those Comey
and all those corrupt idiots now because
of the Twitter dump the Twitter files we
just found out that they were colluding
with big Tech the censor all the stories
with like are they can they get who's
going to investigate the FBI they're in
charge the doj who's going to go after
those guys
a new president comes in to really go
dig a Little Deeper the first person
that's going to do that is going to be
the same time let me just look at what
the center let's go let's go about
passive story guys we got we're not
getting opinions we'll go to the next
one so the scientists story about ESG
okay page seven so GOP versus ESG why
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
Republicans are fighting woke ESG
investing okay so woke ESG investing and
there's a lot of this going on right now
um
why do Republicans have a problem with
ESG the acronym for environmental social
governance principles isn't widely known
outside investment circles but is fast
becoming a popular GOP talking point in
the run-up to 2024 presidential election
the GOP says the top nation's top money
managers are pushing an ideological
agenda at the expense of financial
returns in violation of their fiduciary
duty in an effort to stop public Pension
funds from using ESG as a consideration
when making investment decisions red
States from Texas to West Virginia have
pulled billions from BlackRock and other
money managers despite concerns that
doing so may hurt financially they also
launched investigations into the
influence of big money managers on
everything from reducing emissions
to racial Justice pretty pathetic what's
going on here but but here's what the
scientists did okay the sentence is like
I'm just not going to be playing this
card look like they give a score to
companies okay Tom why don't you talk
about what ESG is so the The Listener
can kind of get a better idea well
there's two things there's ESG and then
there's Dei and what Dei is a let's talk
about that first really quick Dei is a
fair measurement of of women minorities
and all the groups that are in your
company the more diversity means you're
reflecting the community and you've got
Fair hiring practices and everybody
comes on that's Dei ESG is different and
people get the two confused Dei is not a
bad thing it's a sign that companies are
doing things and many people have an
opportunity to work for you ESG is where
you are taking
political
unproven and positional elements and
you're pulling them into your company to
operate for them such as certain
environmental things and certain
governance things so when you take a
look at it you're going from Dei where
you're doing good things you can count
with all the wonderful people that
represent society as a whole they're a
part of your company to ESG that's kind
of I think and maybe and what it's
forcing people to do is make make
Oddball decisions that don't optimize it
I'll give you a simple example the
states operate 529 plans and people with
this little 500 can start putting into a
tax-free College savings account for
their kids many people millions and
millions of Americans have it you don't
have to have a million dollars to put
money in a 529 so it earns tax free so
there's something for your kids for
college but now the funds that are in
there that are governed by the States
they're following these ESG principles
and it is showing that it doesn't
optimize the return so people are going
to be losing out on things like 401ks
and on a 529 tax-free fund that you're
in Iowa you put 500 bucks in find a way
to put a couple hundred bucks a year see
if it grows and you have college fund
for your kid but instead the money
managers are put in handcuffs and
they're forced to make ESG investment
decisions and when they do that it's
de-optimizing the return it's a fact I'm
sorry you don't have enough
environmental investment well we don't
think that's prudent right now we're
looking at the market we're investing in
technology medicine these kinds of
things and we think that's all good
energy sector looks good right now
consumer like uh you know blue jeans and
other things these companies look good
and we're making objective decisions
about what we're investing in the fundra
sorry where's your investment in um you
know in environmental carbon credit you
know Recruitment and it's like wait a
minute you know you're forcing these
fund managers to do things that they
wouldn't normally do because a fund
manager is agnostic about one thing do
these particular sub funds and money
make money are they going to make money
because he wants to he or she want to
get a good grade for managing the fund
and ESG is forcing they're calling it
woke that's forcing money managers into
making decisions they wouldn't normally
make for your retirement your college
fund everything else sorry for the long
answer but this one this one grinds my
gears in a very big way it de-optimizes
what fund managers and money managers
are supposed to be doing for Americans
retirements and 529 plans and things
like that by the way like give you an
idea the highest who do you think what
company you think in America as the icsg
score
Apple alphabet number two yeah Google
number two Intel number three Microsoft
yeah number four Salesforce
number five Bank of America okay I mean
you look at the names Tesla has a low
ESG score they don't have a good ESU
score I don't know if you know what Elon
Musk called uh ESG he came out and flat
out just said yes she's a scam oh wow
yeah he flat I said yes she's a scam and
they're using it as a way to manipulate
shamat big critic of ESG and he believes
in climate change shimada's like I'm a
pro climate change guy I believe in
climate change but I believe he is she
is a scam so uh a musk tweeted yes she's
a scam it has been weaponized by phone
phony social justice Warriors they
target people like Elon Musk they target
people that are not willing to bend yeah
Exxon is a top rated as a top 10 best in
the world for environment social
governance by smp5 while Tesla didn't
make the list think about this Exxon
Exxon is top 10 best in the world for
environment and Tesla well you know what
that means here's the manipulation so
Exxon can go out there and buy carbon
credits you get points for that they can
go out and uh do virtuous virtue
signaling by supporting you know you
know local charities that are active on
this but meanwhile they're a fossil fuel
you know manufacturer and processor so
you can game it if anyone has ever been
part of a company where you have a sales
plan and you get a commission to do this
and this and this and it's not just a
straight commission there's a couple
other incentives in it sales people will
game the plan won't they pat they'll try
to find ways to go around and optimize
what you're talking about I've never
worn them with them no no I don't mean
you Pat but I mean come on dude what do
you mean you people Thomas what do you
mean
what you're saying I get what you're
saying I get what you're saying no no
it's anybody I'm sorry you people when I
meant that anybody who's run a company
or has run consulting or has run things
like the Vault and everything that Pat
runs you know you run into companies who
are trying to run sales campaigns and do
good things for them sales guys and they
say my sales guys just find ways around
it and I said well you need to think it
over because the salesperson is going to
find the best way to manage it well
guess what big companies are doing that
with ESG virtue signaling and other kind
of fake investing to get their ESG
points so if they score on ESG and it
really had nothing to do did anything
really move the ball so I'm with you
when exxon's up there on that you're
like how are you scoring this and how
did they play the game and they got the
points for doing it maybe it's uh you
know a couple million to Bernie's
campaign there's another 200 ESG points
it's probably I bet you if you peel this
onion back it's uh some pretty nefarious
pretty fairest scoring system yeah so
anyways we'll see what's going to happen
much like kind of like the term woke
wasn't always a bad term like five years
ago when it sort of came into the
nomenclature it meant like all right you
kind of get what's going on and it's
kind of taken a life of its own these
days now if it's woke you're it's a bad
term I guess my question is when ESG
started
was it like all right it's sustainable
investing it's stakeholder capitalism
we're concerned about the environment we
are concerned about green energy we're
concerned about
um air pollution clean water you know
all these things you see these companies
BlackRock Apple Nvidia PayPal Verizon
Walmart Hilton like the list goes on and
on
so what changed meaning like it
initially it was a good idea all right
let's invest in companies that care
about communities or the Earth or
well-being much like how woke was like
let's address issues that plague society
and social societal issues but at some
point it's taking a turn for the worst
like what Elon has said is like all
right it's gone completely overboard
it's gone completely woke like at the
end of the day it does it just come down
to returns is that the problem is that
they're so concerned with so social
issues just think about what Elijah said
Exxon is top ten and Tesla's not on the
list so so when you think about Exxon
what give me I'm going to give you a
word let's play Word game ready I'm
gonna give you a word you tell me one
word that comes to mind Michael Jordan
basketball go messy soccer Neymar
Brazil Trump America Biden sleepy
Sanders
Communists Exxon oil Tesla electricity
green energy
like you realize like no I I don't know
if like
yeah no I get it so so so the same
people on the left that are saying we
should get away from oil give a top 10
to Exxon
and the company Tesla who has created
the movement of electric cars to get
away from using gas vehicles is not on
the list just because Exxon has publicly
said I'm gonna do good things please
forgive me and Tesla says yeah we're
doing good things I don't want to
publicize it but this is how we're doing
good things but Tesla gets a bad score
this is hypocrisy at its best and Elon
is absolutely right in this interview so
so do you understand the point I'm
making here completely yeah and that's
where I'm asking where it went wrong
meaning the initials where they went
wrong right so so it's kind of like this
let me give you an idea what it means
how was the you know the question about
how credit scores uh uh what do you call
it uh measured okay how is credit score
measured like FICO scores how's it
measured right hey you know Experian
Equifax TransUnion whatever okay imagine
you make all your payments on time
you make every single payment for your
house your rent your credit cards
everything's on time and you manage your
credit well okay but but you don't use
a credit card by Amex because Amex gives
XYZ amount of money to a climate change
organization because of that your credit
score went from a 780 to 620. now B of A
doesn't want to give you a loan to buy a
house this is the best explanation I can
give you for what this is the the method
of counting successful credit score
which is paying your [ __ ] on time has
been manipulated on who you're not
giving money to wow how the hell does
that make any sense it doesn't that's
the best way to explain ESG
does that make sense makes complete
sense and and so and people should get
judged to pay things on time not get
judged for doing this and elon's making
a good point
yeah you know who was also uh you
brought up DeSantis but you got to give
a shout out to CFO of Florida Jimmy
Petronas for highlighting this kind of
stuff he does emails all the time saying
we're what defunding BlackRock is that
essentially what they did in Florida
they also did it in North Carolina
but um this is the importance of talking
about these kind of things I I wasn't
too too familiar with ESG up until about
I don't know six months to a year ago uh
but it's starting to be something that
why is it taken in these
fund manager so long ago an idea like I
I want to look at different schools for
the kids okay one of the schools first
30 seconds I said so let me ask you what
is the top priority of the school what
do you think are the top challenges what
does the school thing are the top
challenges America is facing today
School says oh number one on the list is
climate change oh Jesus I'm like oh yeah
that's right that's that's number one on
your list yeah okay not not raising
great kids not not raising Future
Leaders how's your school now it's it's
climate change is your number one yeah I
mean I can't wait to send all my kids to
your school absolutely they're going to
be running in the dark yeah you go to
another place and so and I say so what
do you think about capitalism hey what
do you think about this so what do you
think yeah the number one issue is you
know gender equality number one
inclusive number one is this number one
is Dei number one like yeah listen
you're doing and saying things to please
somebody rather than the priority is
what kind of kids are you developing
values principles leadership all this
stuff that's what we value right so
anyways this is throwing a lot of people
off and I'm glad they're getting held
accountable right now even though
Bloomberg is coming out saying ESG
Community should push back and you
should get after him oh you saw that
article yeah you know man pushed back
hard you got to fight back hard the pr
press reacts to the attacks all the ESG
people are getting okay tough guy all
right yeah got it you're right relax
while you're giving your your level of
hypocrisy and contradiction good for the
scientists this is another reason why
people feel very comfortable that a
descent is is not afraid to go after
guys like Larry Fink I love it I love
the fact that he's not afraid to go
after guys like glittery thing hold them
accountable
hold them accountable okay so let's go
to the next one here next story do we
want to hit a Twitter or let's just do a
Bill Maher story real quick let's do a
quick Bill Maher story a little bit
light lighten up dude uh isn't that a
line from your comedy video that you did
yeah yeah uh so let's see which one I'm
going to know what page are we on okay
there we go that's why they turn that's
why they turn into a bunch of hoes
I love that coming up Bill Maher mocks
people who are offended by everything
committing Bill Maher and Miss Pat whose
real name is Patricia Williams mocked
people who are offended by everything
people go crying and they're ready to
jump off a ledge at any little thing you
say is the kids that were raising today
they don't work for [ __ ] we give them
everything that's why they turn into a
bunch of hoes and be crying all the time
it's page eight instead of being honest
to kids they want to pamper them and
make the word easy for everybody The
World Isn't I cuss at my kids and people
say how can you cuss out your kids I
said because when they get into a real
world and somebody says F off they won't
fall off the ground you know Mar is an
absent Mars and the outspoken opponent
of cancer culture and political
correctness in 2021 he said liberals
should stop catering to the people who
just want to [ __ ] uh Tom thoughts I I
think he's this is refreshing this is
absolutely refreshing catering to people
that just want to [ __ ] it's one thing
to have a point it's one thing to move
the ball forward on something important
for society it's quite another thing
where you protest for the sake of
protests because what you're really
trying to do is is move things in into
power and by the way there's a direct
line with this goes right back to ESG of
all these people bitching about stuff
and then it goes back and then they're
they're they're executional uh lever of
bitching is an ESG policy I I love this
and I think he's calling it and Miss
Pack is calling it and I think there's a
big thing in here about kids the bizdoc
Babe is a teacher and we have kids today
that are treated differently and are too
sensitive and are incapable of debate
and she is dead on I I don't necessarily
cuss at my kids but I don't I don't cut
them any slack they they hear it from me
when when things not right because no I
don't want someone to challenge them or
wanted to be date with them or anything
like that in the real world and have
them shrink back and be you know
unequipped and unprepared
yeah Bill Maher I've said this before I
mean that's my guy if there's anybody
that I think is just kind of nailing it
these days it's Bill Moore I know that
obviously you're tight with Rogan and
that's sort of like who you think is on
Goat Mountain Bill Maher's on my goat
mountain and it's not because he calls
out the right it's also because he calls
out the left and who are we talking
about right now it's specifically if we
want to name names the people that are
doing the complaining are young people
gen Z who
you know are just kind of entering the
real world for the first time and
they're bitching and complaining and
they haven't done anything yet a lot of
what you talk about are the doers don't
have a voice and the complainers have a
loud voice these days if you're 22 years
old you haven't done anything yet you
haven't built anything yet you haven't
made any money you haven't built a
family you haven't accomplished anything
it's so easy to [ __ ] these days about
everything that you're seeing in the
world and all the plights that you're
dealing with the reality is in America
today in America this is the best most
amazing time we've ever had in our
country as far as living longer
healthier wealthier things are so good
in America and you know just take a trip
to other places in the world and then
come back to America and see if you
still have that same attitude but uh
overall I think Mar is just nailing
everything these days and shout out to
him and his writers because they're
crushing no I mean because I actually
know one of those writers that's on the
on this Real Time with Bill Maher no no
I'm like well but I've done stand up
with him and I just I mean I respect him
uh but it's just uh do you think the
shift is happening because he was so he
was just the Trump
that's all to me because I'm that's from
what I saw in L.A it was just every day
was Trump and like trying to be clever
with the Trump jokes do you think that
this is a shift because he's trying to
still kept because nobody's relevant
when the all those Trump hating CNN we
saw what's happening with CNN do you
think he's making that shift and he's
being so anti you know woke and all that
just because he so he doesn't lose
followers or he's always been this he
said that you know I haven't changed my
positions have always been this it's
been the left the the progressive left
that has sprinted far left like he a lot
of times he'll say this on the show I
don't know how often he watches the show
he says a lot of times Fox News will
praise me right or or Hannity will
praise me or Tucker will praise me in in
the hopes that I'll come on their team
he's like I am not on your team yeah
okay but I'm also not on whatever this
woke ideologue situation is going on on
that side I mean you saw the stats that
he talked about with like that LGBT stat
and how America's coming gayer and gay
yeah and Walker and woker I think that
at the end of the day what we're talking
about is just common sense he's calling
out the left he's calling out the right
and we need more of that in this country
whether it's a Rogan whether it's a mar
it's mother was what pbd and what we do
here
Common Sense will prevail and I think my
only thing is too not to bring up not to
cut you off Tom and I do not want to
talk about Trump but the fact that when
uh Dave Rubin was on his podcast and
they spoke he still can't admit people
like him that really piss me off you
still can't admit that what happened
with the elections and all that [ __ ] was
fabricated it was all made up none of
them could just be like okay I was wrong
because even Dave Rubin was like come on
bro like it's all Hillary and she paid
and they're still like no you don't know
what you're talking about that's only
that's one thing I don't respect is
admit when you [ __ ] up admit admit that
you were duped you didn't you didn't
start it you didn't do it admit that
everything that you said that you were
peddling on your show and all these
people you lied that's what we're
talking about with CNN I would expect
CNN 1000 more if just one day they just
want you guys you know what
we we messed up Hillary did all this she
paid all this money and we believed
there and we pushed it all on you guys
we'll move on that's only that's the
only reason I don't respect them do you
watch uh Bill Maher at all are you
talking to you I just watch his Clips on
Twitter I never watch this show like
watch I don't what is it on HD video
yeah you're not like a Bill Maher guy I
whatever he posts yeah on on Twitter
specifically Twitter I anything that all
of a sudden pops up first of all I think
he's a he's my style of a guy like if we
were to go out and talk and just shoot
the [ __ ] he seems like somebody you can
shoot the [ __ ] with and entertain have
banter conversations he's that kind of a
guy I like I like how he is but I I kind
of agree with what he's talking about as
well uh all I know is this this year
2024 2023 is going to be a rough year
for a lot of people I'm just saying it's
not going to be a good year for fauci
fauci is going to go from being the
sexiest man on Earth
to a bachelor or somebody that no I mean
he's going to be Scrooge at the highest
level like a scrooge type of a guy
that's gonna be I mean you should see in
his reaction when I say what I said
about fauci it's as if I cursed out you
know
yeah I mean oh yeah yeah there's a scene
you have to watch from yesterday's clip
but uh fauci's got to a lot of people
he's not going to be God next to you
he's going to be more closer to a fallen
angel than he's going to be a God in
2023 him Hunter Biden SPF it's not going
to be pretty this year can I see
something about Hunter Biden yeah this
is crazy so I watch SNL a lot shout out
to our buddy Marcelo Hernandez you know
I they did a bit a cold open this
weekend the guy that does Trump uh I
don't know he's actually really good
it's funny and then they had um Donald
Trump Jr come on really no no no no no
and he talked about hey partying and I
said you know what just for shits and
giggles let me put into YouTube SNL
Hunter Biden because clearly there's
gonna have to be something that they've
made it yeah one joke crack process
attitudes this that to me was shocking
there was nothing about Hunter Biden on
SNL that is a layup for comedy 100 like
you talk about comedians like layup
jokes you tell me you can't do a bit
about Hunter Biden smoking crack in his
den in the basement getting money yeah
like you can't do one bit on SNL that to
me is is a red flag that to me is an
opportunity for another company to
launch a comedy channel and recruit
other comedians which we're doing yeah
if your comedians your writer your
improv reach out to us uh value payment
go to Val guys if you are funny
genuinely funny and you know people that
are funny that can write act do stand up
just overall genuinely funny people on
valuetainment Comedy well we posted a
video uh and in the description there's
a submission that goes to valuetainment
we're looking for people we have over
just put the link of the submission
below submission right there put it in
the chat Rob not in the not in common
but put in the chat yeah and we already
have at least 50 people we're going to
start picking people so it's so nice
we're going to be those people unique
names what a lot of followers have
reached out which is uh which is
exciting okay let's go into Twitter
files okay let's go into Twitter not
Twitter files let's talk about uh Elon
musk's poll that uh he did a couple days
ago talking about
whether he should be replaced or not and
the votes came out uh 17.5 million
people voted he said you know out of the
17.5 million 57 percent showed that Elon
should step down as the CEO of Twitter
which this doesn't mean he is no longer
owning Twitter it just means he's
stepping on he'll still be the chairman
of the board he'll still be the owner of
Twitter he'll just have somebody else
operate Twitter and then a bunch of
talks came out so Twitter musk who could
be the next CEO of Twitter Elon musk's
poll this weekend asking followers if he
could step down as Twitter CEO though he
has ignored the results of the vote in
which 57 of he has not ignored he came
out and he said I will be stepping and
I'm looking for somebody there's a bunch
of different names that are popping out
right now uh cerium uh Krishnan senior
director of product at Twitter a decade
ago in 2020 when he was appointed as
general partner of the influential Tech
and crypto investment firm and recent
Horowitz and this year he was taped uh
by musk to be part of his War Room
shaping Twitter into whatever it is now
number two Blake Masters is another name
that's come up after losing the Arizona
senate election in November Blake
Masters apparently wants to Pivot back
into original career path one of the
other guys who helped run Twitter some
of the existing names uh there's even
snoops out there Jared Kushner this
afternoon a bunch of different guys uh
musk's fixer or his new favorite lawyer
a Mormon and a former Morgan Stanley
wealth manager musk's fixer Jared burkel
helped lock in the deal that allowed his
boss to buy Twitter with billions in
loans with Morgan Stanley the head of
his family office virtual is also the
CEO of neurolink anyways there's a lot
of different names that's coming up
thoughts I I want to address the tweet
that you put out there yeah because I
thought I thought that was very
interesting you kind of threw your hat
in the ring and you you kind of made a
proposal right there
um what do you think the the most
important qualities of the new Twitter
CEO should be I so first of all here's
what I did say if you're talking about
the tweet that I sent out let me just
read it so I can say exactly what I said
I said uh because he asked he said Lex
Friedman asked out you know uh I'd love
to come and work and you know do what I
can and then he responded and says in
order for you to do that you would have
to put your entire life savings in it
you you have to be all in if you're
doing this he says I'm all in right
anyways we're on a flight uh to Dallas
yesterday or two days ago Addison we had
a special meeting with uh uh some of our
guys at home office a very very big
meeting maybe the biggest meeting of the
year for a couple people
and uh we flew in you know on the way
there we're talking about this as a town
I think we can take this company to a
trillion dollar valuation what do you
think we start going back in for we're
having a conversation about Twitter
you're talking Twitter yeah it's me
Mario and Tom and me Mario and Tom and
uh Samuel on the flight and we're going
back and forth on what we would do you
know here's we could do this we could do
that we could do this we could do that
and I said you know what uh the only
person that I'm concerned about this
thing would be Jen and Marty's Like Pat
you gotta talk to Jen about this before
you make the difference your wife yeah I
said well even if we took the shop you
know it would be a job because it's a
fight like you know hey would you ever
run for office I would only do this
because I see this as service I don't
see this as money I'm okay financially I
see this as public service because the
world needs Twitter to stay open the way
it is right now that's annoying a lot of
the people from the swamp who have been
manipulating these guys the government
was paying Twitter nearly 3.4 million
dollars the government was paying
Twitter three points I don't know if you
read the Twitter files how much 3.4
million dollars they collect from the
government to say hey move this hey do
this hey do that they bragged about it
in an email to each other okay so I said
to Elon a guy asked me a question saying
hey Patrick would you ever take the job
of being a Twitter CEO of offered I said
yes I would accept the terms Elon Musk
has mentioned publicly with two other
requests salary of a dollar per year a
reasonable Equity incentive beyond my
life savings investment and we would
drive Twitter to a trillion dollar
valuation within five years 100 serious
and I got a bunch of different
commentary uh some DMS some interesting
messages that came out but no we haven't
heard from Elon Musk no I don't have an
interview and play some people like Pat
has an interview I haven't spoken to
Elon I don't have an interview I have
not spoken to anybody on this team no
conversation like that's taking place
but I do believe uh uh uh that this is a
job that needs to be ran by somebody who
is reasonable somebody that can see both
sides we were talking yesterday what
skill set is very important to be
c-suite executive is it more hard skills
or is it more soft skills in a situation
like this I think this is a soft skilled
job this is somebody that's got great
soft skills to be able to work with both
sides yet Scott is a True Believer that
is not going to compromise values and
principles so for this position he has
to weigh out what he values more is it
somebody that understands engineering
more is that who needs to be or is that
the CTO job not the CEO job is it
somebody that's a true believer of
freedom of speech where they're not
going to break you know compromise
values in front is that the number one
value is it somebody that's good at
communicating messages with both sides
that can play as synergist is it
somebody that's not afraid of being
pushed and being criticized Non-Stop and
public humiliation what what value does
this CEO need to have to do that
whatever value is at the top for him
that's who he's going to hire and I'm
willing to bet Elon knows what five
qualities
he's looking for before he decides to
give somebody this job it has to be
somebody that's ran a business before it
has to be somebody that understands how
YouTube elements are working out where
YouTube's given 55 of advertisement to
producers it would have to be someone
that can bring some big podcast names to
be able to put on Twitter spaces which
is really doing well that's a product
that they can do a lot of things for it
has to be somebody that can bring a
Consulting space to experts to get paid
it has to be somebody that understands a
bit of politics and gamesmanship I I
think those are some of the qualities I
would if I'm him but I'm not him it's
not my company I would look at some of
those qualities before I bring somebody
in
with the current climate right now with
everything that's going on in Congress
about Tick Tock right and Adam and
advocate of getting Tick Tock the hell
out of America I agree what do you think
is the upside for Twitter because I
think if you go through the top 10
social media companies number one meta
number two YouTube Google you go down
the list WhatsApp Instagrams up there
Facebook Messenger then you've got a
couple Chinese companies WeChat tick
tock
um at least according to these numbers
as far as uh what is it monthly active
users Twitter is in top 15 meaning
they're not even in the top 10 right now
uh where do you think Twitter could be
in the next five years
exactly what I think a trillion dollar
company I think Twitter can really
compete with everybody and this can be
the WeChat and many other things but
there's a way he has to go about it you
know look there's certain jobs that are
big jobs but you don't get them because
of just money you have to have the itch
for it certain jobs you will be the most
hated man in America is a job like Trump
was the most hated man in America for a
few years he's no longer by the way I
don't even think Trump's in the top
three most hated man in America today I
think he's number one right now most
hated I think he's number one above
everybody right now I think he's the
most hated man in America he's being
targeted by the swamp he's being
targeted by mainstream media he's being
targeted by the left he's being targeted
by universities he's being targeted by a
lot of different people they can't stand
this guy so now watch this anyone that
takes his job anyone that takes his job
if you can zoom in is what he's saying
to you yeah anyone who takes his job
elon's job will be a modern day I know
this is going to sound weird you're
going to be a Rupert Murdoch type of a
guy wow yeah and and if you know like
who Rupert Murdoch was this guy was
never loved except for people that
worked with them and were part of fox
the guy was was hated for ever okay but
he built a 100 200 billion dollar
company I don't know the exact valuation
of fox it's not a job for everyone
especially somebody that uh uh uh if you
want to be liked this is the last job
you want to take well you hit the nail
on the head with Rupert Burdock because
who did he appoint to be to run Fox news
for Susan ultimate no no he had uh Roger
Rogers I'm thinking you're talking about
the current CEO no no so my point is
this with uh you bring up a good point
with the murdochs because I went and I I
kind of went and saw who's running all
these companies with the exception of
Zuck
right we all know Mark Zuckerberg is
running Facebook meta
the last thing you want with these major
social media companies are household
names right now everything the spotlight
is on Elon but if you go down the list
here okay so who runs YouTube now Susan
wojinski like no average person does not
know her name I cannot even pronounce
her last name who's the CEO of Instagram
these days obviously Instagram is owned
by Facebook Facebook and metal we know
Zuck but who's the CEO of Instagram
we don't even know his name his name is
Adam Morrissey okay moseri all right
Mark benioff owns time Jeff Bezos owns
wapo you have all these you know whether
it's social media whether it's major
um news outlets it's very low-key I I
actually completely understand why Elon
would you know throw his hat in the ring
bring in literally the kitchen sink but
then step away and then and then assign
somebody to the CEO that isn't going to
make the waves and the headlines here
because ultimately it's not it's about
freedom of speech it's about Free Speech
it's about the First Amendment it isn't
about Elon I think I mean by the way do
you think he abides by these polls like
I think he does abides Bible I mean
meaning like if he does he like he he
reinstated Trump he said should I
reinstate Trump they did it boom so how
much credibility would you lose if he
doesn't abide by no he he you've seen
the last tweet right there yesterday I
will resign I see you as soon as I find
someone full enough to take the job
after that I will just run the software
and silver teams meaning I think he's
going to abide by the fact that oh yeah
in that sense yeah I actually think I
actually think he will Tom what are your
thoughts on this oh first of all I think
the world the world is
completely confused by this and to the
ignorant Lemmings that are out there
screaming oh you know he's gonna leave
he's gonna leave he owns the company
people yeah that's like my dad saying
okay I'm not going to be the dad of the
family anymore but I am going to be the
chairman and I still make the most money
and I control where we go on vacations
great but he's not Dad anymore he's
stepping down fantastic people don't get
it he's about to become chairman and
he's going to run the software teams and
all the things that he's really good at
and he's going to put a CEO in place
that has those qualities that Pat talks
about there's new features have to come
out we need to attract talent to this we
need to attract user base to this you
need to be balanced on the political the
side of this that's the job of that new
CEO and it's going to be a thankless job
a tough job for for someone who's got
the ability to come in there and do that
and then as you get the users back look
it's 400 oh it's only 14th in the world
but it's 400 million users if that
doubles to 800 million users I think
it's number four or five in the world so
suddenly this thing is going to be right
where we think it's going to be I
believe it's going to be a trillion
dollar company and what you know Elon
Musk is crazy like a fox and a lot of
these critics are out there just finding
something to do and they're being played
baby they're being played he knows
exactly what he's doing it's yesterday
you know it's crazy yesterday we're
having a meeting and we're thinking
about doing something with LinkedIn how
much was the thing that we want to do
with LinkedIn oh yeah it was a thirty
thousand dollars or like unlimited
recruiter access I'm not asking what it
is I'm just saying how much was it
thirty thousand or thirty thousand
dollars yeah so think about it so
LinkedIn has a feature where you pay
thirty thousand dollars right okay so
I I think Twitter can allow people that
are willing to spend that kind of money
to get access to information that others
are not going to have there's so many
ways to create revenues with this
company you know the the saying goes you
know we're in a church you know first
you bring them into the church you
baptize them later Sometimes some
churches that are small they try to
baptize people first then bring them to
church now hey man just come to the
church and look you know what this place
is kind of fun I like this place we'll
baptize you later okay so Twitter is now
bringing people to the church which is
Twitter
you're going to be able to baptize them
later with a product you're going to be
able to baptize people to say I'm going
to spend money on this I'm going to buy
this service I'm going to do that I'm
going to do this and by the way you
realize there's an element of like these
video games Candy Crush and all these
other guys one time I'm in Colombia with
a couple of my friends and one of my
friends is like six hours he's on the
phone like what are you doing
so we're at dinner it's like this I'm
like hey what is he doing he says oh
dude he's so addicted to this game he
spent five thousand dollars yesterday on
the camera what what he says yeah he
bought this he bought that he bought
this how do you think these games are
becoming what
multi multi-billion dollar franchises
because it allows people to gamify you
know how many opportunities there is to
gamify Twitter like you know how many
like imagine if it says you can buy such
and such four hundred dollars
you can buy this for 200 you can buy
this for sixty dollars you can buy that
for 700 there's an element of allowing
gamification for people to choose what
kind of money they want to spend and you
would be amazed if people are spending
four million dollars on a land in
cyberspace or metal world just because
as land is on a beach you don't think
there's some people that would be
spending money on Twitter if you allow
them those types of opportunities where
it gives them a unique you know position
or unique place like how much would it
be well I'll give you perfect idea at
our school think about this when I say
this idea I want you to think about this
so my school okay that kids go to
there's a uh what do you call it auction
okay I'm not going to give all my ideas
I'm just going to get I'm giving some of
them for people to be thinking about
we're at this auction and the number one
parking space for your kid to park and
I'm sitting on like a parking space my
kids are 10 years old nobody driving
yeah okay let me see where this thing
goes to number one parking space where
the kid can park here and walk right
into their classroom they don't have to
walk 10 minutes they will never be late
okay obviously I could care less about
the spot because I don't know how my
kids that are 16. and it's like all
right five thousand dollars five
thousand dollars is the start this is
not going to go past six thousand
dollars
ten oh my fifteen holy [ __ ] 20.
25. 30. I'm like be quiet 35 000 for the
one parking spot okay let me ask you
guys this crazy question how much is the
real estate worth on Twitter when you
log on to have the 10 people to your
left to follow follow the following
people how much is that real estate
worth millions millions are you freaking
kidding me it's that 10 million bucks
like are you are you like imagine go to
go to your profile right who to follow
you have all that freaking on the right
side what the hell you doing wasting
that space let me pay for it well what
is all this [ __ ] suggested stuff for
let me pay for the top 10 spot the
number one spot you know what I would
sell the number one spot for for 30 days
how much are people paying for FTX Arena
to have their logo their 100 million 200
million dollars for 10 years dude that
say that's a 10 million dollar a year
position to have and some people would
pay for it they would pay for it there
are so many ways for Twitter to make
money there has to be a capitalist that
understands marketing and position to
say
here's how we can bring revenues to uh
to Twitter so you're going to need
content creators like a Mr Beast you
need Rogan you need people like that
that are coming on there there has to be
something with those guys you have to
bring humor you have to bring fun you
have to bring the news guys you have to
give the news guy some kind of ranking
credit score there's so many things you
can do to make this the most popular
website in the flipping world but you
need the right person too that's a great
idea this could be a trillion auto
company but anyways I just gotta make
you just throw your hat in the ring No I
gave my ideas and I've got a message
there's a SpaceX a spaceship that just
landed on the back elon's elon's here
he's in a higher path I will say this
yeah the one person we're all talking
about Elon the one person that he's not
in the news he's not in the headlines
but he's got just as much money as
anybody and he's just as competitive as
anyone is Jeff Bezos now you're starting
to see rumors that like Amazon is
developing their own Tick Tock like
strategy stuff like that
elon's got so many eyeballs on him he
can't operate you know he can't do
anything clandestine at this point oh
hell no Bezos he's not looking to be in
the front page of the news he's not
looking to be
you know uh all up in the mix uh
trolling like like Elon I wouldn't count
out Bezos for anything at this point no
way he's he's got his own space company
he's got his own newspaper he's
obviously Amazon uh and now he's looking
to compete with Tick Tock
um I don't know just Bezos is not in the
news these days but he might be when you
don't hear his name just don't think
he's not up to anything Bezos is doing
other things bazo's doing other things
he's having fun right now he's had a
different phase let's do one last story
before we kick it off do we want to do
Kelly and Conway do we want to talk
about zelinski and his trip here yeah
really do you want to talk about China's
economy won't be number one wsj story do
you want to talk about Wells Fargo Tom
what do you want to talk about tell me
what story you guys want to talk about
we'll go to it and wrap up I was gonna
say The Killing what is she doing going
to dinner with with uh Cuomo I hadn't I
saw that and I'm like is it just a photo
op or like what well I don't understand
what the hell are they doing dishes on
her eyebrow raising New York City dinner
with disgraced U.S uh X Governor Cuomo
Donald Trump's former political advisor
insisted Tuesday there was no uh Amor in
the air as she had a private late night
meal with disgrace former New York
Governor Andrew Cuomo at a famous Upper
East Side Italian restaurant Italians
prefer eating to zoom we would have
invited his brother Christopher but it's
unclear that he it's uh unclear that he
hits carbs uh Cuomo is reporting uh
currently single while the 55 year old
Conway is married to attorney and vocal
Trump critic George Conway nothing
romantic I've known Como family for
decades Conway said that dinner dinners
menu for discussion included how they
both had podcasts with same company
Quake media and talk of various
political issues on which they could
find Common Ground like I that just like
just what a random
crazy like besides them they're on the
same podcast company no I have an
opinion what
go with me here okay I think uh Trump is
interviewing candidates for VP he
started looking at Kanye all right
that's as crazy as it gets these days
okay he brought his boy Nick Fuentes now
he's like all right who shocks the
system as much as anybody these days
Andrew Cuomo I don't know there's a
trump play here something's telling me
kellyanne Conway is still in touch with
Trump for sure she was his best flag
carrier no doubt for sure and believe me
the topic of trump did come up in this
conversation at dinner and I don't know
I think Trump is still looking for a VP
and if there's anything that Trump likes
it's being in the headlines and you know
if kellyanne Conway and Cuomo the
disgraced
handsy touchy Governor Cuomo or having a
meal together you know Trump's name was
brought up crazy opinion call it what it
is but I don't know wow Trump's done
crazier things
I I I don't know how to read it or it's
just a couple folks that run in
political circles that have a respect
for each other perhaps that just grab
dinner over the holidays they're not
dumb if there was really something
romantic going on they're not going to
get seen at a restaurant like this
neither one of them is dumb especially
what he's been through and what she's
been through with George I think there's
a nothing Burger I think it was a couple
of operatives having a discussion I
think Cuomo is far far far from the
orbit of who could be you know VP
that's what I think I think it's a
nothing Burger I think it's a Adam's
fantasy I think yeah Adam wants to vote
for Trump but only if Cuomo is
very weird people and videos that's the
way he would be open to the idea yeah I
don't know if I think much of it by the
way but at the same time is she wearing
a skirt
I don't know what she's wearing and uh
you know I don't know I have a photo of
her but I'm a big fan of this of her
she's a talent man if there's there's
certain people you want to have on your
side she's one of them so who needs this
picture more sheer him he does no
question about it so 90 10. so let me
tell you
did he ask her hey can we go out to
dinner I just want to go out to dinner I
want to get a little a little buzz in
the Press I need to do some things I'm
trying to no you know I don't think so
Cuomo is not gonna go quietly into that
good night there's he's there's gonna be
a Revival at some point I mean okay he's
not just gonna but yeah I'm just curious
I'm out and retired he's
he's we have not seen the law the the
last of the cuomoses I mean his brother
is back doing some podcasts that I don't
know who's watching it but I mean dude
is he is he I know how many women came
forward is he gonna get in trouble I
mean there's no joke he's a he's a
politician so he's not going to go to
jail but how many how many staffers came
out and said that he was sexually
harassing and groping them was there a
number enough to win a big election baby
yeah yeah okay all right well listen
it's come down to the end
um uh we today wasn't planned we decided
last minute to do this podcast because
we're not going to be together with you
for a week but uh it's been a great run
this year I think we got a couple
podcasts we'll be doing next week after
Christmas and then we have some big
names that are coming up 2023 and some
that may shock some of you that we're
working out right now with a lot of
interesting conversations are being had
I want to wish everybody that's watching
this a merry Christmas if you've been
with us from the beginning or you just
joined the podcast a year ago or six
months ago or you just joined us in the
last month because somebody shared it
with you and you've shared this with
others when I run into you wherever we
are and we have conversations it's uh
some of the best conversations hey Pat
let me tell you pbd podcast Adam said
this you said this and I don't know I'm
in the bathroom people will say that one
time there so we appreciate your loyalty
We Appreciate You tuning in and uh we
love the fact that you like the format
that we have I I want to wish you and
your family a very very Merry Christmas
enjoy it uh have fun enjoy the
conversations enjoy the meals and then
we'll do this again after Christmas and
then we'll get a chance to wish you a
happy new year take care everybody bye
bye bye